the Joe Rogan experience when I'm asking
this in terms of [ __ ] if you had a magic
wand what do you do the reason why I'm
asking you this is because I've thought
about it I've sat down and tried to go
over it myself and I don't see a
solution that's it's what's so strange
to me is that we have nations inside of
our nation mm-hmm and I don't I don't
want to end it and I don't want to
continue it neither neither one makes
sense to me like to to end it would be
to say you're forced to assimilate you
no longer have sovereignty we're gonna
break the last treaty and disband the
reservations and make everybody just be
in the United States citizen that seems
crazy well everyone is a US citizen
so citizenship was forced on us in 1924
I believe but I mean yes it isn't like
I'm a US citizen where I can't start my
own casino and I can't just do whatever
I want do you understand what why that
is I mean yeah I guess I guess we know I
do know I mean do you and the reason why
I'm saying it this way is because I'm
just I'm just trying to look at it like
from an overhead view like if I was an
alien and I was trying to sort this out
I had no no ties to either culture I'd
be like what do you do with that like
what do you do with that like I
understand these people have been
massively [ __ ] over that the genocide
was perpetrated on their their their
race that they were wiped out both with
disease and by military actions and
soldiers and treaties were broken I get
it but the state they're in right now
when you look at what we're talking
about with these reservations the
horrific conditions and the problems
with drug abuse and alcoholism and
suicide and and despair and self-esteem
and all these issues like what is the
solution what would be mean if there was
an unlimited budget like what what would
you do if you were like if it's
president Shannon if you got elected you
could win right you could be President
anybody was president I think so right
so you won and you became the president
and you you ran on the part of what your
platform was was fixing this gigantic
soar that we have
country our relationship with the tribes
what would you do unlimited resources
you do whatever you want well it I don't
know if it has anything to do with the
tribes I think it has more to do with
the general public
okay well it's about changing
perspective I think I think if we're
properly educated about about history I
think if we really understand who Native
people are and and their importance here
and their importance to continue as
sovereign tribal nations and it has to
start it has to start with with public
education we have to recreate what's
important to us here and and I think
Indian nations have have been here I
think they're a symbol of amazing
prosperity that the country could have
and we've just never tapped into it and
I'm talking about just principles and
values that that we don't seem to to
hold anymore in this country
appreciation of nature our symbiotic
relationship with it I feel like you're
kind of being sarcastic no not at all no
no no no no no no not at all I think
that's one of the major problems we have
in this country is we don't have a
appreciation of nature we really don't
you know and it's not just an
appreciation of it I think it's a
connection to us we can't survive
without it and and we're so interrelated
to everything that happens on this earth
and and we we don't look seven
generations ahead of us to see what our
decisions today are going to do to us in
the future we're constantly looking for
the dollar today and how that's going to
reward our efforts today and we're not
looking how you know what the lives of
our children are going to look like with
the lives of our great great
grandchildren are gonna look like and
and and I think those are the kind of
values that that we need in our country
now and I think that's what's being
debated in the Democratic campaign right
now you know where are our values are we
going to you know continue to support
corporate society and and corporate
sponsored everything or are we going to
start looking at at what we want you
know a hundred years from now well
that's certainly what's going on right
now with the debate yeah yeah and it
seems like corporates winning even
though their spokesperson could barely
talk which is hilarious I mean it just
shows you how strong money and media and
the influence of the DNC is what would
all this education do though and
explaining to people to the American
citizens that are outside of the tribe's
how is that going to help the tribes
themselves what what could be done to
help these problems that we've already
detailed the problems with alcoholism
the problems with suicide and despair
and self-esteem all these horrific
conditions that exist on many many
tribes well part of that is is is not
anyone anyone's problem about ours that
we have to deal with is is sovereign
nations within our our own communities
and how we how we choose to fix those
issues but I think looking outside how
how we can really affect change is
there's something called prior and
informed consent and it's in its
contained within the UN declaration of
indigenous peoples and it it requires a
state or a government to include tribal
nations in the decision-making processes
that affect them so this general this
administration has been horrible at it
absolutely horrible at it the Obama
administration was much better but we
need to be part we need to be the
decision-makers in the things that
affect us so if if you are going
to bulldoze and blow up our sacred sites
to build your border wall it seems like
the proper thing to do first would be to
have a conversation with us and for us
to to make a decision about how we may
can do that a little bit better to
protect those sacred sites and and
natural springs and other things along
along the border instead of just blowing
up everything
[Applause]